okay okay it's a boy psychobabble hair
and we were located on a chump and we
are playing the first step okay okay and
I a hussar I haven't discovered it yet
okay Oh No okay that's a nice gun jay
says uh so super gay shut up I has my
man date you oh sure a better get out of
there after what the [ __ ] up you're
gonna let a woman see how that [ __ ] yep
on the [ __ ] [ __ ] well I'll [ __ ] ok
ok all right now ok quick save this
[ __ ] all right fly the right here you
know when I was like an emo and I'll say
I'm okay okay [ __ ] [ __ ] hell they're
low tier heli rightly channel I got one
bullet on this [ __ ]
oh that is horrifying just hit list wait
to have a gun that's actually like has
Miami I guess the shotgun I like shotgun
Oh what is this Ari here hello sir
you're cute oh good guy get [ __ ] is this
oh oh sorry oh hey it's nice like yeah
yeah very cute hello y de Allison it
takes hours crammed so its impact gonna
you know what does candles I'll take it
you know so we're sure it's like take a
summer sure so give it to ya okay okay
oh [ __ ] sorry oh my god father here you
got some cardio working on his ass he
knows I'm [ __ ] [ __ ] am I supposed to get
up there okay
ok ok gud get gud get gud gud out of my
white girls [ __ ] buscaste on how
thing ok ok over here over here there
you check out this [ __ ] all way
over here living out here on this job is
but you know anybody takes one way I
hear the scared us [ __ ] you know [ __ ] ok
ok yeah i'm here sir that's an old
settler excuse me how you go wake up
[ __ ] come on I got a gun right here get
the [ __ ] up here sir here sir what do
you want we don't need me more trouble
around here had a house ok I'm with the
Minutemen I'm here to help you're with
the Minutemen I didn't really think you
fellas we sent word with one of them
passing traders but honestly I'm sure
most people don't put much stock in the
Minutemen these days after Quincy the
[ __ ] couldn't say we're rebuilding
the Minutemen from the ground Letta
you're it no question there's a Raider
gang that's been giving us trouble we
don't where they're coming from ok I'll
kick their asses thanks friend if you
folks let's tear this [ __ ] let's do
this [ __ ] are they very close oh [ __ ] I
gotta fast travel baby yeah
yeah I know VAT right there ya go roa
yeah
they'll spread into this batch hey de
jesús well [ __ ] my Ally honey picture
that here okay this [ __ ] is a crazy
okay can I catch a gutter cog i think
that the [ __ ] my companion oh I love
with Tony one okay I can't get get good
God gotta get it again let me Tory's
vats real quick mm-hmm [ __ ] I need to
have perception 10 oh you're level 26
[ __ ] that like I do it later
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] okay all right the [ __ ]
this matchup that's how I'm gonna say
how at the [ __ ] y'all day up
[ __ ] well for Trump Trump 2016
shoots [ __ ] has on her event event that
I thought that bad but bad oh baby yeah
yeah yeah I'm here to say the leggings
I'm here to worship your legs baby yeah
but others might next day we guys do
like it I like it God can't get good let
me let me get rid of some less rattle I
did know that [ __ ] okay where are these
[ __ ] yeah that's all this [ __ ] okay I
hear like robotics
who's [ __ ] me hate those [ __ ]
okay I gotta do some [ __ ] hate how oh
there there I'll jump across here yeah
yeah yeah how the [ __ ] yo [ __ ] [ __ ] it
up [ __ ] hello Sam oh god get get
get get get get okay okay says there's
like a [ __ ] ton over here like a [ __ ]
ton and I get over there yeah there oh
[ __ ] no rock and I take like 10 hours a
low to shed is [ __ ] embarrassing why
I got here and I like it doesn't make
any sense it makes you look like a check
out uh headband they are bumping in
limbo sampling ganda ten tasting bingo
don't we kick in nagatani Gondo cooking
game day I ain't no [ __ ] oh what the
[ __ ]
ooh her booty pissed a lot about you my
god i have that hey I'm saying Jay's
let's just get this over with it on sale
that gag and get can I'll take this
sounds our sake if you don't want it you
know I here betch all right yeah [ __ ]
stone those gonads go [ __ ] this [ __ ]
out well for me cuz i do that
nice guys a lot filthiest mmm can i hack
this database network oh okay that can
but there's a good chap in here you know
that fog has can't gonna open up that
thing with the key just connecting
connecting connecting connecting come on
doesn't love it okay where are these
patches why should sort bubblegum this
game
who's there me [ __ ] here's your
camel toe solution very low dispatch
come on that's okay i got good guess God
God God God God and I say well [ __ ] here
there's a plane Oh skull good God good
good so nice um can't can't get this way
I got a good this way it's just [ __ ]
well very like off the trail Jesus I
gotta go up though
so nothing like the chute de likes off
you know cuz you make somewhere like
friendly lady gauge with me huh okay
yeah just lost the ability to lose your
legs thank ya thank ya so nice let's get
this thing to hate those things
I'm here in the bathroom waiting for you
Batman just waiting for you comment off
now how the [ __ ] did i get to him
show your face come on I dare you is
that it wasn't like an elevator
somewhere all right here here's another
stairs there we go yep here we go [ __ ]
Hawking legs off yeah
[ __ ] this is not good okay let me get
some aid oh [ __ ] the [ __ ] am I taking
that [ __ ] I'm doing so pad right here
now
okay this kind of light in hell up come
on scan them scan them yeah Tom just
likes chaos you know thank you okay
where's the safe where's the safe
Oh graduates what Marion nice good kid
I'm gonna go back well quitting her out
the same the safe was where I was like
over here I [ __ ] hang out of here I
think the state was on the bottom level
see what goodies are there Geddes are
there she says it's a [ __ ] disaster
yeah clean this place up Oh bay bay and
bay bay I got it where the safest I
don't like it was [ __ ] actually get the
[ __ ] out of here how the [ __ ] do I get
out of this place yes I
no safe right there don't think I can
pick that it's not the safe [ __ ] yet but
just can't okay get a nanny and again
out of here
you
we got Chapel cuz I think you'll be
walking us all right you know outside
yes ma'am I'll see ya that sawed-off
[ __ ] cheetahs
unless you're sucking debt by at gina's
takes sweet time getting up yeah it's a
can yeah I kicked Aston that's the best
piece of news we've had so we've been
talking we decided if you came through
for us we joint we want things to get
better so we're in kind a problem a
problem um so that [ __ ] I gotta getta
that mission over now
hmm all right Preston oh you see this
any items here
yeah shut it too much water I Preston
Preston where is it just hanging out to
[ __ ] you down out there hope this rain
lets up soon you know that settlement
you sent me to help they've decided to
join the Minutemen that's great news I
knew you were the right person for the
job by the way you should have one of
these flare guns you can use it to
signal for help from any nearby minute
thank ya thank I'm more useful as we get
more allied settlements eventually
you'll have help wherever you need so
there's something I need to ask at I
don't think I ever told you what
happened to the mini me how i ended up
is the last one all right I figured
you'd tell me have you heard of the
Quincy massacre no no I thought everyone
in the Commonwealth where the Minutemen
betrayed each other I was with Colonel
Hollis's group a mercenary group called
the Gunners was attacking Quincy the
people there we were the only ones that
came only a few of us got out alive we
never found a safe place to settle as
long as you I'm not about to give up
that's why I'm talking hey I appreciate
that does that mean yes okay good good
welcome aboard I feel like this is right
don't worry uh-huh
the leader of the Minuteman has our last
leader was just one good now it's York
I've got something talks a lot okay okay
oh that's it guys we just finished the
first steps tough xtreme Legends